welcome back everybody so we're going to
have Max Hopkins and he will tell us
more about high dimensional expanders
okay so uh
the basic structure of this talk is I'm
going to talk uh last talk we saw sort
of how to develop the spectral Theory
by the way is the sound okay everything
sounds good okay
um we developed sort of this L2 or
spectral theory that we saw I didn't
explicitly write out approximate parts
of all but we saw this approximate
orthogonal basis you can imagine it's
easy to recover this type of L2 type
result
in this lecture we're going to look at
relations to higher moments things like
hyper contractivity that we discussed
um and I won't actually prove
hyperconductivity on on HDX for you but
hopefully I'll sort of convince you that
you should at least be able to do this
morally
um there's actually one thing I wanted
to mention before I go off uh
into this higher Norm vein which is we
saw in the last talk
um
this approximate eigenic composition I
just wanted to mention that you can
actually use this approximate eigen
decomposition to get bounds on the real
spectrum of these operators so the down
up walk and the aminoase operator I mean
this is maybe sort of obvious if you're
familiar enough with linear algebra but
I just want to mention that you you can
prove fairly directly that like the
spectrum of say the up down operator or
any of these walks is actually
concentrated in strips around these
approximate eigenvalues so this the
spectrum of this sort of looks like K
minus I over K plus or minus
of gamma and similarly you can prove
that the spectrum of the analog of the
noise operator that we talked about will
also look like row to the eye plus or
minus o of gamma I mean this is not
something explicitly you really need
because you already have the approximate
the composition but it's nice to know
that you can get these sort of strict
bounds on the spectrum of the of the
operators okay so I just wanted to
mention that
um and now let's actually talk about
this sort of higher Norm Beyond spectral
type behavior on HDX
so let's recall from I think it was in
no arms talk that or maybe uh
maybe even an Essie's talk this was
mentioned
so I'm going to recall a simple version
of hypercontractivity that's typically
just called the bonami Lemma
I'm not sure it was actually introduced
in this form but this is like niceness
of low degree functions
States roughly or some simplified
version of the bonami Lemma says that if
I have any function
on the hypercube
and I look at its like degree I heart
but the low degree parts of the Fourier
decomposition are smooth or Nice in some
sense in particular that I can compare
the four in a worm of fi and it's not
too much bigger
uh some factor of 2 to the O of I here
people know the exact answer but we're
going to be happy with some approximate
thing here
um
versus the two Norm squared or I can
just think of this as Florida versus two
Norm
and we also saw that this had some
really nice applications within Boolean
Fourier analysis the one that I want to
recall is small set expansion
um and I'll probably sort of take this
as my uh
the thing that I'll focus on throughout
that I don't have to talk about bonami
so we saw that this had an application
do small set expansion of the noise
operator
of T row and maybe we'll just take a row
as a constant I'm not going to deal with
what the exact dependence on row is in
these things either we basically saw
that if I drew
X from from the cube
and then I draw y as like a noisy copy
of X right resampling each coordinate
with say half probability or probability
one minus rho but this we take like a
row Noisy Neighbor of X then no one
proved that the probability that uh for
for any set
for any subset of course of elements in
the strings in the queue for any subset
of the cube that the probability that y
lies outside of a given that X was in a
so you can also think of this as you
know conditioned on being in this set a
when I apply this random walk what's the
probability that I leave a this is
typically called The Edge expansion or
edge isoprimetry of this type of set
um and he proved that on the cube this
beautiful statement called small set
expansion that this is at least one
minus
the density of a to some constant that
I'm not going to worry exactly what the
what the constant is but but what this
says
um
is that small sets expand near perfectly
right I think it was stated that sort of
much of the mass is near the boundary is
one way to State it in terms of these
balls we got this type of small
expansion behavior and one way to think
of this uh
in the world of sort of versus spectral
expansion which is what we were looking
at these these eigenvectors in the
second eigenvalue is that in like
standard Theory something like cheaper
inequality the second eigenvalue
corresponds to sort of the worst case
expansion bounds over T row so you could
use this type of material to show on an
HDX that you have some sort of worst
case type of expansion over T row but
this is a statement that is that says
something different and it's much much
stronger it's not that the worst case
you know like always you have a quarter
of edges leaving or something like this
this says if you have a small set truly
almost all of the weight is leaving that
set it's much much stronger property and
later we'll see sort of uses of this or
variants of this in pcps and hardness of
approximation I'm going to let Dora do
that part of thanks
um okay but so the main question for
this talk
is whether this Behavior generalizes to
high dimensional expanders so you know
can
and regeneralize
bonami or SSE
to high dimensional expanders okay so
that will be our main focus
um except that we're we're maybe jumping
a little bit ahead we haven't we haven't
talked about hyperconductivity or small
set expansion type behavior on any sort
of object beyond the cube I mean we've
mentioned no one mentioned how you can
look at like different types of Cali
graphs but we didn't really look at
domains beyond the cube and hcfs are not
exactly the first domain that you would
you would look at for this type of
behavior and indeed Noah mentioned one
particular domain that's very
interesting which was the p-bias Queue
at the end of his his talk
um and so I want to focus first on
hyperconductivity on product domains and
we'll give an example for the pbiased
cube and then most of the rest of the
talk will be trying to understand why
High dimensional expanders sort of mimic
the structure that you'll see in in
product spaces in the cube and then why
you would expect that we can sort of
Port certain results like small side
expansion hyperconductivity from
products to high dimensional expanders
that's sort of the overlying structure
that will we'll go through here so let's
look at uh let's look at product spaces
wait I'm sure all of you know what
product spaces are but I'll just be very
uh very explicit so we'll look at spaces
where we have some ground set and some
distribution over the ground set so in
the pbias cube this would be
just a plus minus one or let's do zero
one
um
this would be zero one a bit and and Pi
might be P biased right so Pi might be
Pi of one is equal to P Pi of zero is
equal to 1 minus P so this would be a
single P biased bit and then we're just
going to tensor this
a times so now our domain
is this Cartesian product
of K copies
uh maybe I'll just write it as
Omega to the to the K and then this
comes with this tensored uh distribution
correct this
okay where Pi of like
you know V1 through BK
is just the product of
each of the individuals
so it's just the independent
product of these individual coordinates
um
so let's now look at this simplified
question
can we extend this Behavior to
product spaces
and Noam already sort of gave a hint to
the answer to this uh in his talk when
he was looking at these intersection
structures in ekr
um the answer is no at least naively you
cannot do this
um and let's let's see why so let's look
at the example of the pbias cube
particular we'll look at sort of the
classical extreme example we'll look at
dictators which have come up now
I think in most of the talks
so a dictator one eye just to be very
explicit we can just think about this as
the set of elements in
zero one to the K such that x i is equal
to one or equivalently this is just a
function x i
um and I'm not going to go actually I
guess I guess no one talked about the
p-biased characters this is a degree one
function right it's it's controlled by
one coordinate if you write it out in
the 40 composition it's one character
um normalized uh and so if we if we look
at bonami then we expect because this is
the degree one function if we had
hypercontractive type Behavior we would
expect that the four Norm should be like
constantly related to the two Norm but
let's see what actually happens
but if I look at uh
expectation of one eye
to the fourth this is a Boolean function
so this is just
expectation of one eye
which is p on the P bias cube right
because every bit is one with
probability P instead of probability
one-half right before we were
essentially okay because dictators on a
standard Cube are not sparse functions
but this is a sparse function and it
comes through in this analysis
so now let's look at uh
Square two Norm okay same same argument
right this is expectation
of one eye oops
squared which is P Squared and now think
about p as being like asymptotically
small with K like I don't know something
really small like one over root k or or
something like this then in this case p
is much much larger than P Squared right
it's like asymptotically larger than
case uh B squared whereas again we
expected this relation to be within a
constant
so in the sense the bonami Lemma pretty
drastically fails for this type of
function we don't get hyper-contractive
behavior and maybe a more direct you
know uh okay we can do these
calculations and see that it fails to me
is coming from like the expansion type
of community it's always more natural to
look at the small set expansion version
of things so we can also see that small
set expansion is going to fail by the
same example if I look at uh you know
the probability over X and then even the
P bias no no I'm introduced this pbiased
version of the noise operator
we draw y
you know from like the half half noisy
version again we look at this expansion
we look at the probability that y leaves
a given that X is in uh sorry let's do
let's set a to be the indicator
that X is in this set well what's the
probability
remember that we wanted this to be like
1 minus the density of the set we wanted
to be in this case the density is p it's
really small we want almost all edges to
be leaving but this clearly is false
right the only way that I can leave the
the in the dictator here is if I
resample coordinate I but in the
definition of the noise operator like
the half noisy noise operator I only
resample I with probability a half right
so this is at most
half when we expected it to be like 1
minus P to the O of one which is much
much larger so
again you see sort of the breakdown of
the small set expansion type behavior
and uh you know if you only looked at
like standard expansion before sure half
sounds pretty good but when you're
looking at a small set expansion and
it's like relative uh applications you
really need this type of behavior this
gives you a much much stronger
characterization of expansion throughout
your graphs okay so in products we seem
to have sort of a complete breakdown of
this Theory we don't have small set
expansion we don't have
hyperconductivity what can we do
well again no I'm at the end of this
talk suggested a solution to this which
was maybe really these are sort of the
only problems that not maybe just the
dictators but sort of local functions
things like juntas that as long as I
avoid this type of behavior that I could
reprove some version of small
satisfaction
this is typically called Global
hyperconductivity or hyperconductivity
for pursuit or random sets
um so what was really the problem with
with one eye you know why did it fail
this type of behavior well
one eye is
dense
in some restriction
this is sort of the key issue so one is
itself is a sparse function right it's a
function with density P but as soon as I
restrict
you know as soon as I fix the ith
coordinate to be one I fix one value of
my product
now the density of the indicator is is
one right it jumped from being a a very
sparse function to an incredibly dense
function and a single restriction and
the noise operator is sort of a global
process it doesn't see the fact that
this like one it doesn't see this jump
in density in one coordinate and that's
sort of what has gone wrong here so we
need to avoid these functions like
juntas that upon restricting to a few
things become extremely dense so that
motivates this definition
of global functions or Global sets
so we'll call
a function f that Maps
this product space actually the real
let's you could do it for the reels I'm
just going to do Boolean functions for
Simplicity uh and we'll call this
Epsilon I global
basically if for all restrictions of I
coordinates my function remains sparse
as density less than or equal to Epsilon
so I guess formally I should write uh
for all subsets Tau of uh or for all Tau
in
a choose I so for all possible sets of
coordinates and then for all
values that I can fix those coordinates
so for all Z Tau again
Omega Tau or possible tuples to fix
these two
that the expectation
of f
conditioned uh let's say
X conditioned on the fact that accent
coordinates tau is fixed
to be values Z Tau
should be less than or equal to
Epsilon
so okay like we said
the dictator clearly fails this
definition right I can I can find some
one coordinate to restrict to where it's
where this is one it's not going to be
less than Epsilon and uh in general
you know we can hope to prove uh that
these functions will indeed satisfy
bonami and small set expansion and
indeed this was proved in 2016-ish by uh
evosh lift ships long and menzer and I
think independently by O'Donnell and
Zhao although somebody should correct me
if that's wrong they proved the
following
theorem
uh maybe I'll write it over here
okay
I'm just going to write it in a small
set expansion Forum because I actually I
haven't defined for you over product
space is what fi is there's a
decomposition called the Efron Stein
decomposition that I don't know maybe if
later people will talk about this or not
but I'll just do the smallest expansion
version but know that there is a version
that's the bonami like true sort of
hyper-contractive type behavior
um
which basically said that uh
or any product space
foreign
again there's a more General version of
this theorem but let's let's fix I to be
like log one over Epsilon this is for
the same reason that we saw when Noam
did uh the proof of small set expansion
that he he sort of broke the the sum up
into Fourier levels below log 1 over
Epsilon and above log one over Epsilon
so I'm going to sort of do the same
thing here implicitly in my pseudor
Randomness uh Global assumption
so sufficiently Global functions
expand near perfectly or I'll just say
have a small set expansion
that particular if we look
so the
I guess formally we haven't defined the
analog of the noise operator over a
general product but you can imagine what
it is for every coordinate independently
I resample with respect to the product
distribution with probability one minus
rho we saw this in the P bias case it's
a very natural definition to to extend
um so the probability
over X and then y drawn from some noisy
version uh
of X that's y
uh
so I Define this for for Boolean
functions
I'll just write shorthand
let's say that f is the indicator for
the set a so that we match the notation
over here
is greater than or equal to 1 minus
Epsilon
so again you basically recover
this theorem except I replace density
with this notion of being pseudo random
or Global so in particular like not only
should my function be sparse uh
on sort of the empty restriction
globally it should remain sparse up to
log one over Epsilon levels and then I
get this theorem
and what I'm going to try to convince
you of today
is that this theorem should extend where
I cross how product spaces and I write
gamma High dimensional expanders and
this is this is the theorem for certain
Notions of gamma HDX
and I'll note that this is a in sort of
the
two-sided uh gamma HDX case this is due
to buff now
Hopkins
Hoffman
love it's
and then for a version of HDX that are
called gamma products which I haven't
introduced yet and in some sets actually
capture the two-sided case and an
additional case we'll talk about
um this was proved by Gert lift itself
okay
are there any questions about sort of
this theorem statements or the general
uh behavior on product spaces before we
move to HDX so the rest of the stock
will be about HDX but I wanted to give
sort of this intro of why
why the rest of the talk is something we
should care about
this issue you mentioned it was for
small people
no so if you if you have good question
so if you have P equal to half it's a
simple exercise to show that every
function is Epsilon log one of our
Epsilon Global so up to getting the
wrong constant this actually recovers
the b equals one half version of the
theorem and indeed like
sort of the original study of
hyperconductivity beyond the cube people
first proved these results I guess that
are called like generalized cyber
contractivity or something like this
that are for p bias Cube and and more
generally for products and they depend
on like the smallest atom probability in
the in the product
and so it works as long as P isn't
really small but then it turns out that
a lot of problems like you really care
about this case that the products are
super unbalanced and and then you have
to use this type of global function
hyper constructivity
okay so let's let's actually talk about
high dimensional expanders that's uh
what I claim to be talking about in this
uh in this talk and I haven't done it
yet
so what does any of this have to do with
HDX
well okay I claim
is there an analytic formulation of that
by the way like I like I see that this I
mean Epsilon here is really important I
guess I mean you have sort of like a
fixed Epsilon but is there
like you want to think of it as like a
log Savile thing or or hyper-intractive
so
I mean of course you can phrase it as
bonami but if you want to talk about it
as like hyper conjunctivity the noise
operator or something like this you you
can but sort of the problem is that you
need to be to recover like the standard
statements you would need to be Global
all the way up to the top of the complex
whereas typically in like the
applications that are interesting you're
looking at functions that are Global up
to like some constant levels of the
complex so you you could do this but
only for like a very strong definition
of global I don't know if somebody in
the audience has a better answer maybe
no one yeah
spaces
so everyone yeah is this like kind of
equivalent is restricted like
recent mixing papers
um just like this Global uh
hypercontractivity is like for a
specific class is it like uh equivalent
to some kind of
I mean it could be equivalent to some
sort of restricted version of logs up a
lot more I may maximize every Global
functions but I I don't yeah I don't
know it's certainly not in the
literature
um
okay so why have I been talking about
product spaces
School well here is a here's a claim
products are high dimensional inspectors
in particular they're like perfect
examples of high dimensional expanders
they're what are called zero local
spectral expanders
so remembering back from last lecture
this was the definition that said every
every link of the object should be a
zero spectral expander and I should be a
little bit careful here
again
thank you
next chance
um
I should be a little bit careful because
as I uh I think I erased it but as I
wrote products it's not a simplicial
complex so let me first
show that we can always think of a
product space as a simple complex in
fact we basically did this last lecture
right we wrote out the hypercube as a
simplicial complex the correspondence
here is exactly the same in the product
we had this domain Omega n and then some
distribution Pi n now I can always move
this over to
a weighted
simplicial complex
where the vertices
x0 again I'm sorry X1 not topology
notation
um our again the sum where we append
sort of the coordinate for for each of
these are the parts for each of these
uh
cross
Omega and then I think again
X sorry I should use K
x k will just be all possible subsets
it's the complete multi-partite complex
it's all possible subsets uh
of X1 that has one of each coordinate so
XK uh
all strings
with one of each
parts or coordinate and then in this
case I'm I'm cheating because you know
if if your distribution is p biased or
something like this then you know as
James said we shouldn't just be working
over the uniform distribution we should
actually have some family of weights on
the complex that corresponds to the
distribution so let me just say that in
sort of this General weighted case I
look at a simplicial complex x Pi where
Pi is a family of distributions
over each level of the complex so Pi K
is a distribution over K sets in
particular this is the distribution
that's inherited from the product space
so this is just pi to the K and then
this these distributions Pi I at lower
levels of the complex we won't worry
about them too much but this is
generated just by drawing
uh T from PI K and then choosing s of
size I
uh uniformly at random
from from T So this induces
distributions down the entire complex
and everything that we talked about in
the last lecture all these operators
everything transfers to this uh
everything every all the calculations
Etc we did will work if you weight
things with the appropriate distribution
here
uh okay so in this view now I want to
actually prove that uh these complexes
are zero local spectral expanders and we
basically saw a version of this right a
Reit gave an example so there was a
specific example that Eric gave which
was basically the unweighted case right
Eric talked about this complex that was
end of the K and this is just the
product of the uniform Distribution on
one through n k times and this and she
showed that this was a local spectral
expander because she looked at the links
you know if we have this product
say this is the first copy of Omega this
is the second copy of Omega
Etc in a product space when we look at a
link what is a link a link is like I fix
I fix some value in some set of the
coordinates and I look at the induced
distribution for the rest of the
coordinates if I fix everything but
these two spaces in a product there's no
effects on the distributions here right
the whole point in a product because
that I can fix whatever I want and the
rest of the distributions remain
independent so in this case what I got
when I read explained it was a complete
bipartite graph and this was a zero
local spectral or a zero spectral
extender in our case it's slightly more
complicated because we'll have
distributions that get induced uh on
this on this graph but again because
we're in a product the distribution is
going to be I look at foreign
is now these edges are weighted where
this is like Pi of element one by
development two if I have element three
so I just get edges that are weighted by
whatever the distribution Pi is on the
space
and so what does this look like in in
Matrix form
if I look at the bipartite like the full
adjacency Matrix of this graph
and you know I have uh whatever like the
left side
what I get is you know every every row
of this which corresponds to the weights
of a given Edge is just a copy of Pi so
I just have a bunch of copies of Pi here
I have a bunch of copies of Pi here and
this is very easy to analyze the
spectrum of right it has trivial
eigenvalues
one and minus one from being bipartite
and uh stochastic and then it's rank two
so all the other eigenvalues have to be
zero so this is clearly a zero spectral
expander now you could repeat this
analysis for so this is like
co-dimension two right I fixed
everything but uh two things and I've
looked at this very simple bipartite
graph can anyone tell me how to do this
further uh how did that now
induce the fact that I have a zero local
spectral offender without going through
the analysis for the rest of the links
from a reads talk that isn't somebody
who works on HDX
so we saw something called oppenheim
strickling down here
right that said as long as I have
expansion in co-dimension 2 at the top
level of the complex and everything in
the remainder of the complex all the
lower levels are connected and clearly
if I look at a lower level restriction
of this and I look at the base graph
underlying the complex it's going to be
some connected object it's going to be
complete T part type it just has some
weird weightings but the trickling down
theorem immediately says that because
it's connected if I'm a zero local
spectral expander at the top I'm a zero
local spectral expander all the way
through the complex I think it mentions
something like this with with metroids
because these are also zero local
spectral expanders but this is enough to
immediately get you this result that
products are sort of perfect part-time
dimensional expanders
um
I guess to be sorry to be explicit I
probably should have mentioned I think I
think I redefined these but
just in case
we call a complex heart site if the top
level if if it's uh
if it's K dimensional and the vertices
can be divided
into K parts
like Omega one
through
Omega
okay such that every top level face has
one from each part right just looking at
this as a
sort of graph object
my part-time complex would just be I'm
taking three sets of triangles where I
make sure to take one thing from every
from every part so in a sense High
dimensional expanders are sorry products
are perfect partite high dimensional
expanders notice that uh really I should
say one-sided here
right because this has an eigenvalue of
negative one and in general when you
look at partside high dimensional
expanders the two-sided definition
doesn't make sense right the top level
always has eigenvalues of negative one
from part tightness so the natural
definition on partite HDX is this sort
of one-sided notion
um and for the rest of the talk we're
basically only going to be talking about
part type complexes which have very nice
structure that uh you know they have
they have some notion of coordinates
that will be very useful and that are
more related to products
um
okay uh so we have the products our high
dimensional expanders
uh the interesting thing
of course is the reverse question
which is
do gamma High dimensional expenders act
like products in some sense
so our
apartheid
HDX
product like
foreign
okay so this will sort of be our main
question and the hope is going to be
that we'll we'll find some notion where
HDX are are product like in a sense
where you know you can look through sort
of these proofs of hyperconductivity
that use types of induction on Dimension
or degree you can sort of hope that I
can use the product like behavior of HDX
to mimic the proof and indeed this this
does work
um and we're going to see sort of
exactly the type of notion that allows
us to to do this
um so the first thing that I actually
want to talk about is uh
sort of the opposite of what we did
before
we looked at a product space and we said
we can move the product space to a
simplicial complex now I want to sort of
look at the opposite direction I want to
say that I have apartheid simplicial
complex and that really I can think
about it just as a joint random variable
right if I have if I have a k
dimensional
are tight
complex
I can always think of this
as a joint random variable
X1 X through XK where I'm drawing a
random case that in my object and then
this is the value of on the first parts
and the value on the second part
Etc after the value on the case part
right so maybe maybe let me draw
image
I have my part-time complex when I draw
a random case set from this it's like
drawing one
element from each component and I can
think about this as generating this
joint random variable X1 through XK does
that make sense as uh the connection
between these
all I'm doing is drawing a random case
head and calling this a random variable
it's exactly the same but it's going to
allow us to talk about things in terms
of marginal distributions instead of
having to worry about links and
restrictions and things like this
um
so now I want to Define
a notion due to girl lift shits and Lou
called a gamma product which is
something that I mentioned
over here which is some sort of
approximate notion of this type of joint
random variable or permanently apartheid
complex acting like a product and
expectation
um
we'll call this sort of joint random
variable equivalently part-time complex
a gamma product
if for all marginal distributions
for all marginal pairs
so this is like looking at a marginal
graph
right I I get two random variables this
would be like pulling the marginal over
a bag of one Omega two and this
corresponds to some bipartite graph and
I'm looking at the corresponding
bipartite graph
um if two things hold
one in this sense
x i x j is a gamma spectral expander
one-sided since this bipartite
and maybe let me be a bit more explicit
on why this is sort of a way that your
object acts like a product what does it
mean to be a gamma spectral expander
okay one way to talk about it is
a bound on the second largest eigenvalue
but we can also talk about it in terms
of how this allows you to decorate
functions over X1 and XJ right so an
equivalent way to characterize this that
a Reit mentioned is that this is true
basically exactly when if I draw let's
say I have a function f that's on
uh the domain of x x i
and I have a function G that's on the
domain of x
J I want to say that if I draw like a
joint pair from this and I look at sort
of the joint expectation of x i and x j
over f uh F times G I want to be able to
decorate these right if this were a
product drawing from x i and x j would
be completely independent and this would
be exactly equal to the expectation of f
over x i and the expectation of G
over x j so we get this very nice type
of decoration property spectral
expansion says that this happens
approximately it does there's going to
be some error term here that scales with
gamma and like the I don't know
something like the square root of the
variance of F and
gee I don't care too much about what
this error term is the point is that
this is approximately true that on the
complex we can look at sort of this
marginal over two variables if we have a
function on the parts this is going to
let us decorate the function into
individual coordinates and while this
isn't like pure Independence this is
sort of like a notion of approximate
pairwise Independence you can think
about it like this
um but this isn't quite strong enough
for us right this is this is saying that
each of the individual marginals has
this in a product space I additionally
have the property that if I like
condition on you know x k being some
value one then the remaining product is
still completely independent right all
the now if I look at the marginal X1 X2
sort of conditioned on XK equals to one
it doesn't change it's the same thing
it's it's still a product I want this
type of behavior to hold as well and
this is basically corresponding to this
would be sort of like having spectral
expansion in the base graph of your
complex and the second notion will be be
corresponding to having spectral
expansion in the links of your complex
this says that I want this to hold
even under restrictions
or conditionings
so particular even if I if I look at any
subset of variables s in
okay without
IJ so if I look at any subset of
variables outside of inj
and I condition on them being
some value
so just think about it as I'm like if I
were looking at X1 and X2 I fixed the
values of
you know omega-3
Omega 4 and omega-5 and now I look at
the conditional distribution
on X1 and X2 I want this condition
distribution to still be a spectral
expander so x i x j
uh conditioned on XS equals CS
should still be
a gamma spectral expander
okay does the definition make make sense
foreign here
so is there pretty one
so this is also I mean these are all
these are all one set they should all be
one side
so these are all bipartite these are all
bipartite operators so I can talk about
the bipartite graph right I have like
a sort of pie to J Direction in the
graph and then I have the data I
direction of the graph so and sometimes
I can talk about like two-sided
expansion of this individual operator
which would be like the operator Norm of
of this or I can equivalently talk about
perspective mentioned in the entire
adjacency Matrix they're they're all
equivalent like sort of the only bad
cases coming from the part tightness so
you usually you can you can think about
these as sort of acting like two-sided
expanders would except you always have
this separate like part-time part that
you have to deal with
it this is not equivalent to uh
one-sided expansion like HDX expansion
spectral HDX expansion when it's
apartheid complex yeah it's a good
question
it's the main Theory okay these articles
um
so
maybe I'll write this
yeah great so James has done my work for
me
it's not immediately obvious that these
things are the same because in the local
spectral expansion I'm looking at the
base graph across many of these
variables in this case I'm looking at
the bipartite operators between all
those variables but it's not hard to
imagine that these are indeed equivalent
let's write this up
parasite HDX
are roughly equivalent
yeah
okay so what are the two
reactions for this
um
so one
is that uh
important that's wrong
any
apartheides
gamma HDX is
a gamma over one minus K minus two gamma
product
and similarly
any
uh gamma product
is hey gamma over one minus a minus two
gamma
so given the form of these can anybody
guess the proof
Let's uh
let's book just it at this case to start
so I I claim that
uh we should already know the proof of
this
um and the reason is that if I look at
the definition of a of a gamma product
if I look at restricting to all of the
variables except x i and XJ
the bipartite operator here just is the
adjacency Matrix of the link right so at
co-dimension 2 when I restricted
everything except two options this
actually coincides with local spectral
expansion
so what are we promised in a gamma
product but we're at least promised that
everything is uh or at least promised at
the top level are have gamma local
spectral expansion so all you really
have to observe for for two
is to observe that the links
of
code dimension
greater than two so if I if I restrict
to say all but three things now in local
spectral expansion I'm looking at like
the base graph on this three-partite
thing
trickling down theorem says that if my
cotimension two links are expanding and
every code Dimension below is connected
then I infer local spectral expansion to
the entire object this is the the proof
that I read went through just the case
for Dimension equals three but this is
the general case of the trickling down
theorem
so it's not that hard to imagine that
this is connected right all of the sub
components are expanders in fact if I
look at any pair of them they're
connected so the whole thing is clearly
connected so this means that
this this version is basically immediate
from oppenheim strickling down there
captures measures correctly
okay this is
one edge with a tiny full video
it doesn't matter the distributions are
induced
well and I think it probably is there to
say like well in this definition of
gamma products here right
um it's just really just saying this is
the conditional the covariance basis
right and then the the stair really just
walks back to saying that the max
eigenvalue yeah of the covarian suitably
normalized is exactly equal to the
second eigenvalue of the below correct
one there's no need to improve the
triple death oh wait say it again so the
one thing here is that okay for each of
these conditional measures you can this
thing right down as a matrix right like
this vectors yeah I'm taking the
quadratic forms
and the variance of variance tree this
is some extra normalization that you
need so if I normalize The covariance
Matrix correctly then the max eigenvalue
of that normalized covariance Matrix is
exactly is exactly the second
magnetology of the slope writing Block
in your definition of the usual
definition of HDs but in this in this
case we're only on two components and
typically when you look at the link here
on many of the components there's some
difference between looking at
like looking at only the operator
between part one and part two and
looking at the operator on the global
object
right so it's like having local
covariance matrices for every bipartite
part
but I think it's a very similar view to
like the spectral Independence view
which the quickly will will talk about
but I think the only difference is
largely them in spectral Independence
you look at this covariance Matrix
across the entire base graph but here
I'm only looking at the I'm looking at
all of these like individual covariance
matrices across the parts
okay
okay all right sorry okay
now we're worried I've done something
wrong
I think it should be fine enough no I
think with criticism is correct at the
top level
okay sorry yeah so these are the only
yeah the really the only difference
that's really the only difference it's
like looking you look at these bipartite
graphs between the two coordinates
versus looking at the entire base graph
that's the only difference between these
definitions and you just have to show
that there isn't really a difference
expanders
then you connect them by timing the tiny
measure between them
that it doesn't interested
in the basement
I think yeah but but the links they're
always they don't care about the links
or expanders but then
I would think that you will work lyrics
yeah let's see if this already arises
it's just if you look at trickle down
yeah because and just you look at
connectivity it seems like a very weak
condition but it's the usual thing I
don't think it's a yeah I think it's the
same exactly the same
[Music]
after and if something somehow there's
something wrong we can we can issue a
correction
um yeah trickle down I forget it goes
down to Dimension zero is that yeah yeah
so trickling trickling down implies that
if if your Links of protection greater
than two are connected that's good you
should have a reminder and
the co-dimension two links
are gamma
spectral expanders
then all of the links in the complex all
the way down to the base graph are gamma
over I mean you can do this a little bit
more carefully but uh they're all at
least together over one minus
whatever whatever I wrote up here K
minus two uh
okay so I have 10 minutes I wanted to
sort of sketch the proof of this version
so this uh actually appeared earlier in
the literature this is a result of
dictionary
from 2019 they used it for some
agreement testing type things so before
it had been introduced in this context
and really we've already seen the proof
it's just a part-type version of the
trip like that I've done again but we're
more careful using these parts I
operators
um so let me at least give you sort of
the skeleton of how the proof goes
all right
foreign
said basically all of the action is that
the k equals three
case right this is where we just have
a three-dimensional complex
and the general case basically follows
by an induction once you have the
three-dimensional case
um so our
goal
is to bound
uh
Lambda so let's let's call this
bipartite operator between x i and XJ
The Matrix is is that my J we're going
to show that this is less than Lambda
sorry less than gamma over 1 minus gamma
and what do we get to assume we get to
assume that whenever I fix a value in
one of these parts and I look at the
induced distribution over the remaining
parts then it's a spectral expander so I
sort of get to assume foreign
wrote that if we look at sort of these
conditional version of The Operators if
I look at any V and one of these subsets
and I I guess V should be in if we let's
let's uh for Simplicity let's just focus
on I equals one and J equals two it it
doesn't matter without loss of
generality
so
basically for all the
and the third part we get to assume that
MV of
one two is a spectral expander and we
want to induce just like in the
trickling down theorem we want to use
this local expansion to induce Global
expansion
uh and we'll do this through the
following so we'll use uh the two
function characterization of bipartite
expansion we'll say that Lambda
M12
is equal to the
maximum over
I guess f is a function over Omega one G
is a function over Omega two
orthogonal to one uh such that both of
them have Norm one
this is just like variational
characterization
of uh m12f
G so this is what we want to bound
so
again the high level idea of the proof
is we're starting with this Global
operator we want to localize right just
like we did in the trickling down
theorem we want to somehow
first Draw Something in omega-3 and then
look at the conditional distribution
here over which we know it's an expander
and then unroll this back to uh the
global expansion of M12
so let's start with functions f and g
that sort of realize this maximum so we
want to Upper bound uh
M12
f
G and the first step is just apartheid
version of the first step that was done
in trickling down what we want to say is
that this is equivalent
so here we can view this this is just an
expectation over the variable X1 X2 of
uh F of X1
G of X2 right this is what this
bipartite operator does this is an
equivalent way to write it some order
what we saw with the adjacency Matrix
and the uh in the triglyn down theorem
and again we're going to say exactly the
same thing which is I can either draw
from the marginal X1 X2 to generalize to
generate the sum or I can draw from X3
and then conditionally I can draw X1
and X2 conditioned on the value of x3
and this will generate X1 X2 with
exactly the same distribution so first
drawing on X3 and then conditioning on
X1 and X2 is the same as just drawing X1
and X2 from the marginal distribution
right it's like law of total probability
or something like this
so we can say that this is equal to
the expectation
over say Z drawn from
this third variable over here
of the local inner product right of M uh
one two on this so we fix Z here and we
look at sort of the induced Distribution
on Omega 1 and Omega 2.
um and this is equal to
these sort of localizations just like in
the trickling the standard trickling
down theorem
uh how much time do I have five five
minutes
six six minutes okay so the proof is
really largely this avistric Lane town
which you saw in it reads lectures so
maybe I'll try to just hit the salience
components of this so the idea just like
it was
and the trickling dot theorem is now
that we've localized we want to take
advantage of the expansion of this
operator we can't do this naively
because even though f and g were
globally orthogonal to one these local
parts that are over this restriction
might not be right so we need to divide
F and Z into the parallel and
perpendicular components like a standard
trick and an expansion
so we'll Define FZ parallel uh
we'll write this as the inner product of
FC and one
times one and then F per Z will just be
F minus
F parallel Z we do the same thing to G
and then we expand out you know let's
let's just look at this component we
expand out this inner product and we get
sort of four terms
I'm just going to write m12z as m for
for Simplicity so we get mfz parallel uh
gz parallel
plus MF perp
Z
F perp Z
plus uh
MF parallel Z
G perp C plus
MF perp z g parallel Z
okay the point is that these two terms
die
right because this is something that's
orthogonal to one and this is parallel
to one this is parallel to one and this
is orthogonal to one so these terms
become zero we only have to work on
these terms and maybe here I'll sort of
skip because this is exactly what we saw
sorry I should have written GC here but
this is exactly what we saw in the in
the trickling Dots here right the
we now applied the spectral expansion
here right and we moved to gamma Norm of
f z
perp times Norm of gz
Urban okay you have to do some
calculations here to rearrange things
but I claim that if you use like amgm
and koshy Schwartz a bit you'll
eventually get to the following
characterization sort of rolling things
out in the same way that trickling down
does where you'll end up with one minus
basically we'll unroll these to F
parallel minus F and that will have some
component here and some component of
parallel so you'll end up with one minus
gamma
times mfz parallel uh G parallel Z
Plus
uh gamma times
FZ
I think just FZ
squared plus
g z squared
over two and recall that this was
actually inside an expectation on Z so
when I look at this term
in expectation the expectation over Z of
f of Z squared is just the expectation
of f which is one right so this ends up
being one plus one over two is one and
we just get this additional term of
gamma
here we again use this trick that a Reit
used where we we notice that the
parallel parts
are really just the adjacency matrices
applied to f and g right this this sort
of expectation this can really be
written as like the bipartite operator
M13 of f
let's see it's maybe good to formally
confirm this if you haven't seen this
sort of thing before but this implies
that we can bound this this is like
uh looking again at the expectation of Z
this is like one minus gamma
expectation of Z of m13f Z and similarly
m23f
Z which is just the inner product
so moving over here sorry for the board
space this is just the inner product of
M13
f
and n23
G which we uh may I guess we should have
made the Assumption at the beginning
that this is the worst possible all we
need to do is found the worst one of
these so the spectral Norms of M1 3 and
M23 are at least as good as m one two so
we eventually get to bound this
as gamma squared
sorry uh Lambda M12
squared Norm of f
Norm of G but these are both one so we
end up back at exactly the same equation
that we saw when a reap did the proof
which was 1 minus gamma times Lambda so
we we started with bounding we started
at this guy which was equal we chose f
and g since this was equal to Lambda M12
so this says that Lambda is less than or
equal to 1 minus gamma Lambda squared
plus gamma and you can check that
they're only two possible ranges of
solutions to this we have the
possibility that Lambda is greater than
or equal to one and we have the
possibility that Lambda is less than or
equal to gamma over 1 minus gamma
this is the case that we wanted
in trickling down we assumed that the
underlying graph was connected so we got
this for free here this is not for free
right you have to actually prove
that these bipartite operators are
connected what we know is that the base
graph like we know that we're a high
dimensional expander and so we know the
base graph is connected in fact it's an
expander and this means that if I pick
any two points in Omega 1 and Omega 2 I
can certainly find a path between them
but it might go through omega-3 right
the path might go through the third part
and the key observation which I don't
have time to write out in detail is that
if I sort of write out this
path between u and v you know I start at
U and I go to W1 through WQ
see if I fix some wi that's in part so
say that this goes through the third
variable
well this is part type so both of the
edges have to go out both the wi minus
one before it and the wi minus one after
it have to be in this part and moreover
they have to be within the link they
have to be within the Restriction of wi
by definition which means that
these two paths exist in uh in the link
of W1 which we also know is connected
and as an expander so I can replace
this path from W minus 1 to w i plus 1
in here I can replace this with a path
inside the link
we should do this here so I can replace
with path
in the link of x
uh wi which entirely runs between Omega
1 and Omega 2. so if I repeat this
process anytime I hit omega-3 spectral
expansion or really just connectivity of
the complex promises me I can always
replace it with the path in here which
gives me connectivity of this operators
rules out this option and gives us the
theorem okay I think I'm out of time
sorry for going a minute or so
questions
[Music]
yeah you just you were gonna say
something about maybe hyperconductivity
and so presumably this was yeah sure so
so if you look at the proofs of
hyperconductivity so the proof using
gamma products is due to Norm uh to uh
girlish it's Lou
um I mean they do this induction on
degree which I guess is a little
different but so you can look for
instance basically at the Efron sign the
composition you look you can look at
some proof of the bonami Lemma based on
Efron Stein either by doing some sort of
induction on N or you can do it in
induction like the degree of the
components I guess the key observation
is that typically when you're dealing
with these Efron Stein components these
uh
foreign
operators where I like re-randomize some
coordinates at s in the complex and you
can basically do the entire proof just
by using the following assumption that
if I re-randomize sorry outside of s and
I rewrite my outside of T that this is
equivalent to re-randomizing over the
intersection of s and t and you can use
this gamma product structure to very
easily show that on a gamma product that
this has spectral Norm o of gamma and
you can basically go through these
either inductive type degree or
Dimension type proofs just repeating
this fact over and over replacing where
this is typically where Independence is
used in these proofs so if I replace it
everywhere with a so of gamma what I get
is a version of the Panama where then as
a corollary small set expansion where
everything scales with this of gamma
spectral layer
the global function
oh uh
I mean this you would see in the proof
of like hyperconductivity on products
itself
um
I mean we showed us an example that like
dictators won't work
the proof that I like that shows this is
at some point you end up with like some
expectation over the sum of the Efron
sign components squared
uh
sorry maybe like this
and if you could somehow push the
expectations inside you would get like a
four Norm but because uh
because these are correlated you you
can't and so you look at like you look
at intersections of s and t but
basically you pull out the maximum of
one of these so this is after looking at
the four room and doing some
calculations I pull out one of these
terms as the maximum and then you show
that sort of the maximum over these at
front sine things are exactly like the
averages over low restrictions in your
complex you get some term here that's
like pseudor Randomness or globalness
times the tutor this is why you get like
a pseudo-rounded version of global
version
but you you don't lose a dimension
Factor I'm guessing I guess you don't
lose it not yet you don't lose anything
and the thing you were describing to me
when you when you see like approximate
so oh sorry uh you're asking like I'm
asking like so when you when you go from
gamma product to when you want improve
the global hyperconductivity for for
products yeah you this you do do you
don't do like uh you said there's an
induction and you're losing gamut every
step so the question is do you lose it
yes yeah the pentaton gamma will depend
on the dimension so you'll I think
current proofs actually they're really
bad it's it's probably like two to the K
squared after you collect because you're
you're collecting errots are like
everywhere through the proof and
currently you collect a huge amount of
characters
um but and so you know if you if you
take like a very strong local spectral
expander like the ramonesian complex or
coughing and offenheim constructions
this is fine I can I can set gamma to be
as small as I want in terms of Dimension
if I have like a real object in nature
like a symmetric group or something
that's not going to fly right this this
error term will be way too large so this
really only works for these like very
algebraic constructions a very strong
High dimensional expanders I think it's
a very interesting question to get it to
work for uh where you where you don't
pick up these crazy error terms in
Indiana
okay
all right yeah so there are two answers
to this one is that what I wrote here
this this work actually just does the
general two-sided uh non-partate case
but it's observed in in Norm's work that
you can always take a a general
two-sided high-dimensional expander and
I can make it I can embed it into a
part-time complex by including every
possible ordering the top level faces
and you can show that if you start with
a two-sided HDX in the first place
you'll end up with a gamma product or a
one-sided HDX in the second case and so
you can always sort of just embed and
then do things in the parte case and
pass back in fact it's even true that if
you look at we Define some poetic
composition on General complexes
using something related to Ephron sign
here they actually look at that front
side on apartheides even if you look at
this embedding like if you had met a
two-sided complex and you look at the
Fourier composition it's exactly the
decomposition you could get on the
parasite complex so even like the
function the compositions match up and
you can sort of always just talk about
apartheid complexes in this two-sided
case if you have an unordered one-sided
HDX essentially nothing is known this
entire theory that I have said I mean
you can bound the second eigenvalue
which is used for mixing and stuff but
beyond this we know absolutely nothing
um so the two-sided case sort of reduces
the parts I the one-sided case is open
any more questions
okay so let's think Max again
[Applause]
so